it's obviously a very difficult but
important film to put people to watch it
got me thinking about the power of
movies in general what can movies do as
a medium that maybe other things can't
do I think that we have to we can't
underestimate the power of film it's its
ability to heal its ability to destroy
its ability to uplift and encourage
making a film that is about dealing with
social injustice that challenges norms
and and take themes from those applied
to our lives you know it's very
encouraging to me it's absolutely
beautiful to watch that some of the
shots are incredible heartbreaking
though what both your characters go
through in many characters in the film
it was it a difficult process to film to
have to go to those places a lot of
people's just it's just still to know
about my personal history um with sexual
violence and I want to not only portray
my truth and the truth of so many people
accurately but also what happened to the
man in my life at that time what
happened to my family what happened to
our community um I just want to tell the
truth all I know is on that plantation I
felt our ancestors I asked them please
use me I remember action and the next
thing I remember is I was surrounded by
the crew and Coleman and everyone and
we're all sobbing I had no memory of
what I did have any of it the things we
all felt that like you know we're down
there filming on these plantations you
feel the psychic trauma of everyone
white and black of what we've
experienced on these plantations what if
people told you about the film when they
have seen it what's their reaction being
like challenged challenge
don't know what to say and I think
that's the success of a movie like that
is the real success of a movie when when
when someone walks inside a theater and
they walk out a different feeling
something different you know that it has
an impact on you emotionally and that's
the thing I think that's been what I've
sensed from most people is the impact
and then the visceral emotional powerful
impact that it's had on Pete on on
people it's an assaulting movie and it's
intentionally so it I mean it's really
trying to open up wounds and initiate
conversation and be as nates as an agent
of change in light of the recent events
what would you say to people who are
apprehensive about what you miss Mamie
and I would say that the most important
thing is to to continue to educate and
to empower yourself like that is what's
essential that's what really matters
that we we cannot continue living in
this world standing idly by and letting
other people be oppressed or allowing
ourselves to be oppressed we can be our
own hero so at least know that know what
you were capable of standing your power
strange fruit hanging
from the poeple trees
you